my name is jay garrick your world is in
danger when you created the singularity
above central city you also created a
portal connecting our two earths where I
came from I was a speedster like you
they called me the flash before I
arrived on your earth losing fight but
the man named su and he will do whatever
it takes to ensure he's the only
speedster in any world zoom has been
sending metahumans from your world to
fight me you want to go home you only
have to do one thing what's that
it's good to go out on a high note
there you go it's like you think these
things just grow on trees or something
anyone close to the flash all of you are
in a lot of danger
this team that you have here I'm patty
spivot
Kendra Saunders he will follow your lead
they'll do what you say
and fuzzy inside I can feel y'all
you don't get no your you want to be me
today you want to be hero heroes die
only if you can catch them since what is
that a thing
about eight months maybe if you save
Star City you might get one too
oh you don't know who I am do you people
here deserve better
deserve someone to be brave for them
what's happening to Ray is my fault even
when we're out there we are not out
there together you both almost got
killed tonight because you didn't have
each other's backs we're all desperate
we've all been made to do desperate
things ready people go to bed you don't
come out the same
you
hey youtubers it's Charlie so new
footage from arrow in the flash this is
gonna be a breakdown just like normal so
let's get going this is gonna be a
little nonlinear and I just broke up the
trailers to exclude the stuff that we've
already seen like they had a lot of
footage from previous trailers that it
isn't really relevant big stuff first
we've all seen the pictures of zoom this
is what he actually looks like it's kind
of almost a colorless suit with blue
lightning now this is just a
distinguished him from Grant Gustin we
hear Tony Todd voicing him but we're not
supposed to know who's underneath the
mask so later in the season it's like a
Darth Vader mask thing one of the
potential theories is is that zoom is
actually a future version of a good
character now who has just twisted and
turned evil as he says in the trailer
he's trying to take the powers of other
flashes so that he is the only flash it
seems like they're gonna quantify the
Speed Force this season they didn't
really address it that way in season 1
beyond people trying to fill their tank
the reverse flash was trying to fill his
Speed Force tank so that he could get
back to the future he needed to recharge
himself in the comics though the Speed
Force is not an infinite resource like
you know you you increase your ability
to tap into it like Barry Allen slowly
gets faster and faster he gets better at
harnessing it but there's a maximum
level of Speed Force that can be
achieved so when you have two flashes
around that gets cut in half
so if zoom wants to get faster he needs
to get rid of the other flashes and he's
already taken Jay Garrick speed when we
do go to earth-2 in episode 2 we'll
probably get that backstory these will
probably be flashbacks too right before
Barry created the wormhole and as you
can see like in the corner of this
flashback scene this is actually
Harrison wells from earth-2 so we will
see Tom Cavanagh like he's a series
regular so he'll be in most of the
episodes of this season but it's gonna
be earth to Harrison wells
the next big thing is just a couple of
the new villains that zoom is going to
be throwing at Barry Allen namely dr.
light I think this is earth to dr. light
even though she's a good character on
earth one not sure who this is it could
be dr. alchemy it could be just like a
minor change to a comic book character
well to find out when we get to that
episode this is sandy man he's
definitely going to be in episode 2 but
we also see Vandal Savage he's not
supposed to show up till episode 8 and
they have shot that like they have shot
the big crossover episode so I'm
guessing that's what this footage is
from a lot of you have asked me when
Hawkgirl is showing up I
know exactly when she episode is gonna
come in I'm just thinking it's gonna be
the first for most of the really big
good characters are probably gonna debut
in the first four or five episodes the
next big one I know for sure is patty
spivot this guy here most of you will
recognize as the amazing Michael
Ironside he is gonna be playing Captain
Cold and golden gliders father you will
find he is the giant [ __ ] behind the
[ __ ] this scene here with Martin
Stein looks like it's the firestorm
matrix going a little bit nuts before
they finally bond with Jay Jackson now
there's a lot going on with that
character that they've changed from the
comics so we're gonna to wait to see it
to see how close to Jason Russia is I've
heard it said that he's like a complete
departure from the comics they're not
doing Jason rush because they did him
last season and they wanted to change
the character quite a bit but if you'll
notice here they're underneath the
particle accelerator where the
reverse-flash
last year was keeping Eddie locked up
this is like his underground lair so
this location is gonna be special for
some strange reason moving to the arrow
trailer looks like the birds of prey
episode is gonna be Willa
and both Canaries which I'm totally cool
with is this a slight departure from the
comics because we don't have Huntress
totally okay with it because it looks
badass when they do resurrect Sarah I'm
sure there's gonna be a whole lot of
questions about the mechanics behind it
just think about it this way the Lazarus
Pit isn't gonna work for people if
they've been dead for more than a year
but Constantine is able to throw some
extra juice on top of that they did say
that they would address why they can't
use the Lazarus Pit on everyone there
there will be a good explanation because
it's like well someone's dead while you
just want to just throw them in the pit
that is why at the end of episode 1 the
person in the grave there whoever that
ends up being that's gonna stick they
will stay dead that's what the producers
have said most of the rest of the arrow
footage is pretty self-explanatory you
see Felicity looking at a tape of Ray
Palmer
she probably finds a way to communicate
with him and that's how they find out
that he's not dead this moment with mr.
terrific is pretty funny with him you
know trying trying to just like guess if
Oliver Queen is really the green arrow
like nope nope the jawline isn't isn't
right the inside joke is that mr.
terrific is the third smartest person on
the planet so you'd expect he be able to
spot the green arrow right away the
minute Oliver walks into the room like
Oh yep you definitely you're that guy
and here we see Nyssa fighting Merlyn
totally predictable of course she's
gonna try and reclaim her birthright his
daughter of the demon
and I don't think I've said it before
but damian darhk-- is gonna go on the
flash he will crossover just like the
heroes will crossover this year
technically anybody is fair game to
crossover between any of the three shows
so new flash this week and new arrow be
sure to subscribe to get everything
a new round of the reverse flash ring
giveaway whenever I post those videos so
just be ready for that
in my Gotham video and my Walking Dead
Q&A should post tomorrow bye mean
Walking Dead might be wednesday before
arrow I'll just be posting schedule
updates on Twitter and Facebook just
just like normal so if you guys haven't
seen it I just posted the daredevil
season 2 trailer we have Punisher we
have Elektra is going to be crazy you
can click here to watch that and you can
click here to watch the New York Comic
Con legends of tomorrow panel they they
didn't take arrow or the flash so thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tomorrow